вчора q у лютому ти від рано potsdamer
platz транс формується кат берлінале
[музика]
[оплески]
тягу особисто червоне дуричі враховують на
катрин денів
[оплески]
пенелопу крус річарда гира та роберто
патисону
бардин любить xii rock озерця люблять
берлін тут фани розпусти it свої спальні
мішки для того, щоб куб і такий струм
часто їх вже продано онлайн проте
пише годину ти направо цим касам завжди
утруднить до сеансу меча кв-3 роки
nokia б у початку черв'яка свої
владні ледве освоєні спалахує шприц і
на порожні
тут у залі він ширший і знов-таки але на те
є покірному тут дебра не людей до них
продаєте.
так мови про попкорн один із братів
розділів програми бореллі на la pride
досконалі кулінарного кіно з purge
відкоркували від фільму віку мультики про
їжу
а потім відчуття вище до нас з
травами берлінської кухня батько для кого
ти за над російською їж, але може бі-2
дати вечірки брели нали геть відривають у
різьблених q. місця
[музика]
тут зустрічаються шляхи ново чеки на педро
slam по бачаті
і ніби бабусь і ідеальна для тих хто
кулю та за автографами
1 кіно малюка пропана на вечірку
потреба запрошення свистну можна з
пробувати і прорвалися а просто так араб
там почистити